so as we continue our discussion on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic 4 what we
do now is we pick up with the death of
Johnny Storm now Johnny Storm dying was
a huge deal it was a very big deal and
the reason why is because throughout the
history of the Fantastic 4 the only
person who ever really died kind of was
Ben grim and that was why we saw the
Fantastic 4 traveling to the realm of
the one above all and that's what we
learned that the one above all is
effectively Jack Kirby or at least some
people say is Jack Kirby in all honesty
it could be Jack Kirby or Stan Lee it's
just people cite that because it was in
comics I can't really blame him for it
but the fact remains that with the death
of Johnny Storm this is actually
preluded by an event called The War of
the four cities and if you guys recall
our discussions in the early videos on
Hickman's Fantastic 4 we had talked
about how the future version of Franklin
Richards had traveled into the past to
visit his younger self and wake up his
powers but he had also told of Valaria
Richards that there was going to be a
war of the four cities now within this
story we pick up in part with the Future
Foundation now in the last video we
talked about how the Future Foundation
was a group formed by Reed Richards
using children and the reason why he
wanted to use children is because
they're not impacted by the world's
politics they don't make their decisions
based off religious motives they don't
care uh about political allegiances all
they care about is what their
imagination can let them achieve and so
they're effectively untainted by the
real world and so using children allows
to basically do whatever he wants to
when it comes to the idea of trying to
solve the problem of everything about
trying to make the world a better place
and so with this war of the four cities
we're actually going to have to delve
into some history of Marvel Comics now a
lot of this is currently being covered
in my series a history of the Marvel
Universe but some of the stuff we're
going to talk about we haven't gotten to
yet now with regards to the first of the
four cities this is old Atlantis now in
Marvel Comics way back in the day when
the Earth was basically new knew when it
was when life was appearing for the very
first time the celestial showed up on
Earth and they began experimenting on
humans on primitive man and they created
the deviants and they created the
eternals and then they left normal
humans alone save for the fact that the
genes of normal humans were modified so
that at some future point in time they
would begin developing superpowers for
some people this was a predisposition
towards being bitten by a radioactive
spider and becoming Spider-Man instead
of dime for other individuals it was the
activation of a gene that would grant
them Powers which was the case of
mutants but the fact remains that with
this period in time those humans who
were not enslaved by the deviants after
the eternals had basically bailed off uh
began forming their own cultures and
their own civilizations and the central
Hub so to speak of civilization on Earth
at the time was Atlantis it was a giant
trading Hub technology was Advanced far
more than it is right now in Marvel
Comics which is interesting and we'll
explain why here in a second but it was
this massive uh interweaving it was like
the Roman Empire before the Roman Empire
and so what ended up happening here is
the celestials came back to basically
see uh how their work how their
experiment was progressing and the
result was that the deviants believed
that the celestials was wanting to take
over the world and so the deviants
attacked the celestials now while this
was happening the advanced citizens on
Atlantis realized that this conflict
would likely lay waste to the surface
and so what they did is they immersed
their city in domes of an unknown
composition in preparation for the
coming destruction and that's exactly
what happened the war between the
deviants and the celestials initiated
What's called the Great cataclysm
basically meaning that almost all
technology was wiped out and Atlantis
sank to the bottom of the ocean and so
once Atlantis dropped off you had
various themes and various groups that
were forming but within Atlantis you had
a subsect of people that carried on the
tradition of the old ways they never let
go of the past this continued on until
the modern day and this is part of the
war of the four cities these people who
hold on to past Traditions who don't
really follow the ideologies of neyar
the Submariner have come to the
conclusion that it's high time that
Atlantis take over the surface they
basically return back to the surface
world and begin conquering all over
again and so what's going to happen here
is that they are going to find
themselves in a conflict with what are
called the universal Inhumans now after
the celestials had showed up on Earth
and meddled with the genes of humanity
the cre race on the far side of the
universe had realized what was going on
of course they had been fighting the
Scrolls for quite some time time but
because the war took place across the
universe you had different Battle
Stations you had different territories
that operated as military campaign
points and things like that and the
Earth was in a very strategic location
uh it was basically in a place to where
if it were conquered it could easily
sway the tide of battle and so what
ended up happening here is the cre saw
the celestials meddling with the genes
of humanity creating the deviants and
the eternals and so what they did is
they took a subsect of humans and they
modified their genes so that when these
humans were exposed to The teren Mists
they would undergo a transformation into
any number of races who in turn would go
into those particular races start civil
wars and allow the cre to uh to
basically take over that planet and then
continue their expansion of their own
Empire now somewhere along the line the
leader of the cre race the Supreme
intelligence realized that if this
happened long enough eventually it would
lead to the C's own destruction and so
what ended up happening is the Supreme
intelligence order that all of these
inhuman projects be completely
eliminated and all of them were except
for five you had the chameleons you had
the bedon and you had a handful of
others of course you had the Inhumans on
the planet Earth and so this represents
the second of the four cities and what
happened is that these Universal
Inhumans the races that exist way out on
the on different parts of the universe
have decided that it's time to take over
the planet Earth now with regards to the
third City this is what's called the the
forever City on the planet Earth there
is a guy named Herbert wendam but most
likely you've heard him referred to as
the high evolutionary and he was a guy
from the 1930s who was obsessed with
genetics he was actually a really big
deal he was really involved with uh the
studies of Mr Sinister we'll actually
get to a discussion in my videos on a
history of the Marvel Universe with
regards to Mr Sinister because he was
responsible for oh a lot of different
things he was responsible for um Cyclops
the meddling of his powers when he was
younger was responsible for uh the
creation of the weapons plus project
which led to Captain America it led to
Wolverine it led to Deadpool Mr Sinister
was behind the motivation and why it is
that we know that if Cyclops and Jean
Gray ever had a child it'd be wildly
powerful Mr Sinister is behind a lot of
things that have taken place in the
realm of Science and Marvel Comics as a
whole but because Herbert wendam because
the high evolutionary was so obsessed
with genes what he ended up doing was
basically performing experiments on
himself the problem with this was he was
considered Crazy by his contemporaries
by various scientists in the 1930s at
the time and so he was effectively
ousted from the scientific community and
so he took up residence in a place
called Wonder Gore Mountain and what he
did is he began uh basically modifying
the genes of animals in order to hyper I
guess to to speed up their evolution to
basically make them humanlike so to
speak and the fact that they could talk
in terms of the fact that they were
bipedal so on and so forth he had his
group called The Newman well while all
this was happening he also had the
intention of taking over the world and
so what he did is he went underground
and he created a place called The
forever City and the forever city was
basically a location whereby he had an
evolution machine it would allow him to
basically speed up the evolution of all
beings on the planet Earth all of whom
would swear allegiance to him because he
would present himself as their leader
the problem with this was that when he
activated the machine he considered it a
failure because of the fact that the
machine actually forced those who were
exposed to it to revert in evolution
meaning they would go back backwards in
evolution they wouldn't go forward and
so he effectively abandoned the forever
City and so as time progressed and
various underground creatures like the
mids and so on and so forth discovered
this forever City they began calling it
The Lost City of the high evolutionary
this represents the Third City in the
war of the four cities and the reason
why is because those who are currently
occupying this territory have decided
that it's now their time to take over
the surface world now the final City in
this discussion and the one that
actually leads directly into the death
of John storm is the negative Zone and
the forces of annihilist now what this
does is this actually picks up after an
event called Annihilation now for those
of you guys who never read Annihilation
it was a really really good story and it
actually coincided with the events of
Civil War and it was really interesting
the way these two stories compared and
contrasted with one another and the
reason why is because the the connection
between the two was Richard Ryder of the
Nova cor and what had happened is that
while Captain America and Iron Man were
feuding on the planet Earth in the
negative Zone anilis had basically
discovered the negative zones equivalent
of the power Cosmic the power that
Galactus wields and so because anilus is
obsessed with killing everybody in order
to ensure that he can't die that no one
can conquer him annihilist took over the
Negative Zone and then invaded the uh
main 616 universe and began unleashing a
horde of uh of its forces it was called
the annihilation wave and it basically
spread like a plague throughout the
Universe conquering planets killing
everything that it came across it was
one of the most impressive displays of
death and destruction in the history of
Marvel Comics now where this led of
course to the capture of galatis and
different things like that going on and
there were a lot of themes that were
taking place and it even led into the
formation of the Guardians of the Galaxy
under Star-Lord what ended up happening
here is Once annihilist Was Defeated he
was basically confi confined back to uh
back to the negative Zone he was
basically stuck there and so what ended
up happening here is the Fantastic 4 the
Future Foundation and these various
forces uh were going about their own
normal business but within the Marvel
Universe you had what I think was called
the cour of the negative zone or the
court of of annihilist or something
along those lines but it was basically
the remnants of the annihilation wave
who had taken up residence on Earth and
were operating to ensure annihilist
could actually come back and succeed in
wiping out all life in the earth 616
universe and so what ended up happening
is that because Reed Richards was the
first person to discover the Negative
Zone because he's consistently had a
portal that accesses the Negative Zone
the court had basically surrounded the
backer building by virtue of of jobs and
businesses and so on and so forth and
then invaded the backer building and
opened up the portal and so for the
first time in Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four Franklin Richards lets
everyone know that his powers have
returned when he wipes out the forces of
uh of the annihilation wave or the the
preemptive forces but what happens is
that the uh the Future Foundation
Franklin Richards and and Johnny Storm
and those guys go into the negative zone
for the purpose of destroying anil's
forces to ensure that he can never
invade the Earth 616 Universe again and
so what happens here is that while
they're doing the best they can
ultimately they're overwhelmed because
anilus has billions of soldiers billions
with a be he's got so many soldiers it's
unbelievable and so what ends up
happening is the Future Foundation
basically bails out but someone has to
stay behind and they have to basically
lock the door and then randomize the
access code so that no one can figure
out how to gain access again no one can
get in and no one can get out and so
what ends up happening here is Johnny
Storm stays behind and this to me is one
of the best moments in in Hickman's run
because Johnny Storm is not he's not
scared he's not afraid he doesn't care
he's he's angry and he's confident
because he turns around and he says a
billion to one and then he just says
flame on and then that and then it
immediately cuts to the end of the comic
now when this happened when Hickman
revealed that Johnny Storm was basically
dead it took the come World by storm
there's no better way to say that it it
it sent shock waves no there had never
been an instance when Johnny Storm had
died because the Fantastic Four just
don't die it doesn't happen sometimes
the X-Men die sometimes Captain America
gives up there's been a couple times
where Captain America supposedly died
but it turned out he was alive you know
Thor died and Thor disassembled during
the events of Ragnarok but the members
of the Fantastic Four don't die that's
off limits you don't kill them and so it
was a huge Sur RIS to see Johnny Storm
killed off now that being said with
Johnny Storm being dead with Fantastic 4
issue number 588 Hickman gave us a comic
that had no words it was literally all
just images but I will tell you guys
right now this is one of the best Comics
that you're ever going to see and the
reason why is because it literally just
gives us stages we don't have to read
what's happening to know what's going on
and what's really interesting about this
is that because Ben Grim was the one
that had had to basically watch Johnny
Storm die that had to watch Johnny Storm
sacrifice his life this impacts Ben Grim
more than anything else and what this
does is it initially picks up with a
call to Arms I mean the Avengers
basically everyone shows up everyone's
like oh my God Johnny Storm's dead
because in the realm of Marvel Comics
The Fantastic Four are basically royalty
guys it's like watching a prince you
know or a king or queen die you know it
is it's it's an insane thing to see and
so the superhero Community whether
they're villains or otherwise are in
total shock and so of course you have
Thor you have Wolverine you have the the
new Avengers more or less Captain
America Iron Man they show up and they
visit the uh the Future Foundation they
visit the uh the Fantastic Four and the
response from Ben Grim is he doesn't
know what to do you know he's just kind
of lost here because despite the banter
that he and Johnny Storm had the fact
that they would bicker all the time once
you got past you know what seemed to be
bitterness between the two all you found
was love you know Ben grim and Johnny
Storm had a strong connection with one
another because they were effectively
the best of friends and we knew that
because when it came down to it when it
came down to the Fantastic Four fighting
together Ben Grim had Johnny's back and
Johnny had Ben Grim's back but now in
the eyes of Ben Grim no one's got his
corner you know no one is is behind him
and so what happens is that when Susan
storm returns from her Mission she's
told that Johnny Storm is dead and again
the the shock on her face is absolute
absolute shock and absolute you know a
crushing sensation because once we get
into day three we learn that with her
brother being dead she spent almost the
entire time isolated she's been away
from everybody she will not let Reed
Richards touch her she will not let
anybody have anything to do with her and
so on day four Reed Richards goes to his
weapons facility in the backer building
and grabs the ultimate nullifier now for
those of you guys who don't know the
ultimate nullifier is a big deal this
thing is capable of just wiping out
anything now you know what it destroys
it's relative to the uh to the drive to
the ambition and the intelligence of the
person who wields it but because
Richards is in such an emotional state
and because he's so angry and because
he's so intelligent he could simply
press the button and wipe out the
universe if he wanted to and that's what
he does he goes to the portal of the
Negative Zone he effectively you know
accesses it is he's not able to cross
through into the portal but he can see
into the inside and he sees anilist and
he basically threatens him with the
ultimate nullifier and anilist just
presents him with the shirt of Johnny
Storm and that's all it takes that's
that's all it takes and so Reed Richards
just kind of walks away and so what we
do is we move to day five which is
effectively the funeral for Johnny Storm
we see everyone here every almost every
single superhero that's ever been
important in the lives of the Fantastic
Four are present here and so as these
individuals are talking to one another
as they're speaking with one another Ben
Grim gets angry now this I think is one
of the best absolute best moments of the
story because with with the the stages
of grief you know the stages of of
dealing with someone who dies anger is
one of the most prominent and one of the
most dangerous stages depending on you
know how close you were to the loved one
that you lost and so what ends up
happening here is of course Dr Doom
actually vacates uh ladia for a time he
puts Christopher nard in charge and he
actually leaves and goes to uh pay his
respects to the Fantastic Four but we
also see Spider-Man spending time with
uh with Franklin Richards now this will
be important because what's actually
going to happen is there's going to be a
story where Spider-Man works with
Franklin on how to deal with the fact
that Johnny Storm died and this again is
a is a really good story if you ask S if
you if you go you you tweet comic pop
and you ask him what do you think about
Spider-Man's you know conversation with
Franklin Richards after the death death
of Johnny Storm he'll tell you this one
of the best stories that he's ever read
in the history of Marvel Comics and so
we switch over to Valeria Richards and
the Future Foundation and what's
interesting and what I hope you guys
notice about this is everyone's dealing
with the situation in their own way
initially the Future Foundation have
their own their own ideas the thought is
maybe we replace um you know uh replace
Johnny Storm with someone else with
She-Hulk storm black panther Wyatt
Wingfoot who has long since been an ally
to the uh to the Fantastic Four and a p
a close personal friend of Johnny Storm
but she erases all that and she says the
only thing they need to do before they
do anything else is kill annihilist and
so what we do here and this this I said
this is why I think this is one of the
uh one of the best moments of the
entirety of the story is we pick up with
Ben grim and what happens is that on Day
26 Ben Grim meets with uh with Bruce
Banner and with Donald Blake the human
form of Thor and of course we see that
that that Donald Blake has a stick or
his Cane which if he hits on the ground
it will turn into the the hammer of mner
and he'll become Thor and so what
happens is they present him with a uh I
guess with an image of Johnny Storm and
initially Ben Grim doesn't want to have
anything to do with it and so Donald
Blake transforms into Thor and he and
Ben Grim begin fighting one another and
then Bruce Banner changes into the
Incredible Hulk and they start fighting
all three are getting into a conflict
and they're battling and initially this
seems as though they're picking a fight
but what they're doing here is they're
letting Ben Grim work out his anger
they're letting him work through his
hatred and his rage because Ben Grim is
so strong if he were to freak out and if
you were to just start attacking
anything he would almost lay waste to
the planet but both Thor and the
Incredible Hulk are two of the only
people in existence who can withstand a
beating from Ben Grim almost completely
unfazed and so this is why I say this is
such a great story or such a great
aspect of the story because this is
basically just Ben Grim coping with the
death of his best friend and so what we
do as we begin to wrap this up as we
begin to bring this to an end is We join
Reed Richards on day 29 and this is
Hickman kind of bringing us back to
reality this is Hickman bringing us back
to the story saying okay you know you
guys have had your time to focus on the
death of Johnny Storm we have to get
back to the bigger picture here we have
to get back to this great big huge story
Arch that he's giving us and so while
Reed Richards is going over his list of
things the idea that the the Negative
Zone may be invading the planet Earth
the idea that the universal and humans
want to conquer the planet Earth
Franklin Richard's power set these are
all uh these are all important things
that are uh you know a major threat to
them you know galatis possibly trying to
consume Earth is a big deal and for
those of you guys who don't know this
hearkens back to the original appearance
of galatis in Marvel Comics when he
first met the Fantastic Four the fact
that Galactus was forced out on bad
terms was a meant the possibility
existed that Galactic could come back at
any point in time and consume the Earth
and there would be virtually nothing the
superheroes could really do to stop him
but more so than that Reed Richard says
that the Reformation of the Council of
reeds is necessary and this is something
that I'd love for you guys to keep in
the back of your head because this will
be very important later on down the line
but as this begins to come to a close
what happens is Reed Richards is met
with the arrival of his father Nathaniel
Richards
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end and
uh yeah I hope you guys are enjoying
Hickman's run of the Fantastic 4 so far
and I will catch you guys later
peace